there was something I read about you it
was way back in your career and Steve
Martin wrote you a note and said
something like I think you're really
beautiful and you can be a leading lady
is that a true story it's a version of
how I was cast basically and I think so
I auditioned many times for LA Story
and then I did a screen test with Steve
Martin you used to be nervous I was so
nervous and I loved him I mean we grew
up you and I watching him on Saturday
Night Live buying his records listening
to him and then watching how he works
which is super physical and I think that
idea that story came from me saying that
when I was cast in LA Story it was as if
Steve Martin was saying
I think you're attractive you can play
these kinds of Parts when you look in
the mirror You Don't See
a good looking human being
you don't feel unpresentable
I mean I
don't really like looking at myself I
don't I've never have
I like
of fitting and getting in costume I
don't know I mean I think I'm fine you
don't do a facelifts Botox all this
other but think about all of it I'm
like
I ask people all the time like is it too
late like am I is it like now people be
like
well you don't know not only look rested
you look like
entirely different human being did you
ever sit there and say I need to do this
this is no I mean I go to a
dermatologist and there's like you know
you can get like a peel and then they
like there's like a machine and it'll be
like
you know and she's like hold on this is
the first four seconds of the hardest
and she's right you know and then you're
like a little red when you leave I'll do
any of that stuff I I honestly think
like I sh I missed out on the facelift
like at that'd be to me like the thing
like an old-fashioned good one that you
have when you're like 44.
you think you should have 44. I've heard
stories
I see I've seen some horror stories
lately I don't know I'm glad you didn't
do it but I do understand why people
make the choice because there is so much
emphasis
put on
especially women and primarily women
about looks I mean even last year when
we first went on the air with the new
season and there were just so many
endless articles about
you know aging and aging gracefully and
you know
Sarah Jessica's hair is gray and I was
like first of all it's not but who cares
I'm sitting next to Andy Cohen whose
head is covered in gray hair and you've
not mentioned that at all so I
understand why women feel like there is
just there is so much um chatter
peripheral and and opinions so I I don't
think it's wrong I think people should
do whatever they feel
it makes them feel better walking out
the door frankly